I am definitely in my Prime you know we
we made Koozies out of it and it said
not my Prime hole my beer we sold thirty
thousand dollars worth of Jacuzzis in 24
hours so we literally made lemonade out
of lemons I mean look God bless him but
I have always made liberals heads
explode from the very first time I ran
for the State House even
they can't stand the fact that a
minority female would be a conservative
they can't take it and you know even
when I became Governor
um there was a senior African-American
female Democrat and when I became
governor and they were celebrating that
I was the first
female minority governor in history
she went and she said she's not a
minority she's just a conservative with
a tan like this has always been an issue
and so for Don Lemon to sit there and do
that you know Whoopi Goldberg had done
it the day before
one of the three things that you just
mentioned there the the let's talk about
the second one for a second the the
voting situation because the Democrats
obviously do ballot harvesting all of
this stuff you know Trump is is
basically running on that they stole the
election from him last time are you
confident that there would be a
situation where states that are still
doing this stuff so let you know I know
you don't have to worry about say a
Florida or uh you know another or Texas
or South Carolina or South Carolina for
example right but uh I should have said
South Carolina got it um but how worried
are you that California that
Pennsylvania the states that are doing
all of this crazy stuff no IDs no
signature match all that would even
allow for an honest and fair election
well first of all I passed voter ID in
2011 and was vilified for it by the way
I mean the Press said I was
disenfranchising voters they thought it
was terrible and at the time I put the
marker down and I said if you think
anyone can't get to the DMV we will go
pick them up you put money we'll take
them to the DMV we will give them a free
ID and we'll return them home 25 people
out of 10 million for a ride yeah yeah
so you know one I think voter ID needs
to be the law of the land that's not a
republican issue all people want to know
that their their vote is who it is but
what do you do about that before 24
because for Kelly for example it's not
going to do no it's tough right and I
think the worst part of it's the
mail-out balloting I mean that's the
part that I think is that the harvesting
I think Republicans are too nice
Republicans have always been too nice we
need to step up and play the game within
the rules but also call out anything
that we see is wrong it doesn't mean we
say Oh California is always going to do
it you call it out no matter what we're
going to force these states to have to
do it right because if you can get the
people to say it I mean 73 of Americans
say that they think you should have to
show your ID in order to vote that
includes Democrats we need to start
messaging that better and say don't let
them take your rights away don't you
want to know that there's Integrity to
this process it's not going to be easy
yeah it's incredible because most people
do agree you have to have an ID to buy a
bottle of wine and for some reason you
don't have to to vote you also mentioned
the cognitive test so I have to ask you
about the Don Lemon brouhaha we can do
it in two seconds but basically he said
you're not in your Prime and I said hold
my beer I am definitely in my Prime you
know we we made Koozies out of it and it
said not my Prime home my beer we sold
thirty thousand dollars worth of twosies
in 24 hours so we literally made
lemonade out of lemons I mean look God
bless him but I have always made
liberals heads explode from the very
first time I ran for the State House
even
they can't stand the fact that a
minority female would be a conservative
they can't take it and you know even
when I became Governor
um there was a senior African-American
female Democrat and when I became
governor and they were celebrating that
I was the first female minority governor
in history
she went and she said she's not a
minority she's just a conservative with
a tan like this has always been an issue
and so for Don Lemon to sit there and do
that you know Whoopi Goldberg had done
it the day before I know I know the
Whoopi one was actually worse even you
know I mean and then the guy on MSNBC
like you know just sit there and say
that I was like ex trying to show white
supremacy or whatever they'll say
whatever but it none of that phases me
because I know they're worried they know
that I pull from their base they know
that I pull on women they know I pull in
minorities and they have always been
scared by that and so I I know that that
means I'm a threat and I'll take it do
you feel that that's like the key part
of your campaign that you'll be able to
get some of the crossover people because
I was talking about my show there's not
that many people willing to move right
like we sort of know how many people are
going to vote for each side and it's
always about getting that Fringe I
always say it's the to me it's the
disaffected Liberals it's the me of five
years ago that are like wait the
Democrats are completely insane but
could I actually vote for a republican
do you feel like that's sort of your so
the interesting thing is the reason that
I'm a hardcore conservative so I'm not
pulling them over because there's a
moderate side to me it's because of how
I communicate with them you know
Republicans need to see this as a story
of addition we need Asians we need the
Jewish Community we need the Hispanics
we need women we need African Americans
but you don't go to them and say you
should be with us you go to them and say
what do you care about guess what every
one of them cares about their kids every
one of them cares about opportunities
for their kids that they didn't have
every one of them wants a safe America
that's strong abroad my parents were
Democrats until Reagan not because they
were really Democrats but because
Republicans wouldn't talk to them I just
talked to them I go and talk to them I
talk about conservative issues but I do
it through their lens and when you know
what their fears are and you can talk
about conservative Solutions through
their fears they come over that's what
Republicans should want to have happen
we don't have to compromise but you do
have to communicate to people that don't
look and sound like you what's your
policy going to be when it comes to the
media I mean obviously you've got Trump
loves fighting with the media you have
DeSantis who's basically saying I'm
going to ignore media that won't treat
us fairly
you're it seems like you're willing to
go in and play with them but you know
you're not going to get a fair shake you
know if you're on MSNBC or whatever it
might be I mean I'm gonna go do any TV
because if you're trying to win the
hearts and minds of America you've got
to go everywhere but if they say
something's wrong I'm gonna kick back
you know I mean I think that you have to
you really have to do that and I I did
that I think one of my first interviews
was with um The Today Show and you know
Craig Melvin he was pushing back and I
pushed back as hard as he gave it
because I know that my answers were true
and they just want to change the
narrative you know a lot of the liberal
media the hate that they have on me is
they either want me to love Trump 100 or
hate Trump right right I don't I'm not
100 with my husband all the time like
you know but when President Trump would
do something good of course I support it
of course I praised him of course we did
but if he does something wrong I'm going
to call him out too I've always been
like that I've always been a truth
teller in that way and so you know I'll
keep handling it that same way so
actually let's talk about that for a
moment so it seems like there's a
certain set of the Trump base
that thinks that you either abandoned
him or something like that I think we
talked about this once off camera so
I'll just tee it up for you to take it
away from there I mean look I had a
great working relationship with him he
is a friend I called him before I
decided to run
um we I love what we were able to do
together I think he was the right
president at the right time
um but when and in the administration
when I was there he would do something
great I'd support him if he'd do
something wrong I'd say you can't do
this and I'd give him options did he
appreciate that he did there was a great
respect between us and he would always
say well how do you see that playing out
we had a great working relationship but
when I see something wrong I'm going to
call it I didn't think he handled
January 6th well I called it out I stand
by that so you know those that don't
like that I fact that I called him out
that's exactly what I did when I was in
the administration that's exactly what I
do to my friends that's exactly what
I'll do going forward and he knows that
about me is any of the stuff that has
been played on Tucker in this tapes and
any of that is any of that changing your
feelings on any of that or do you think
there's any more of a gray area there so
I haven't seen much of it but what I
will say is all of that should be
transparent they should release all of
it I think it's important I think the
courts need to see it I think the press
needs to see it I think the American
people need to see it and if someone
broke the law they should go to jail and
if someone didn't break the law they
should not go to jail I mean we need to
just open it up for everybody to see
it's weird how so many people in the
media are screaming that these tapes are
being released it's like well this is
public knowledge say more than anybody
should in the old days isn't that what
they liked right they more than anybody
would always complain if things weren't
released the problem is they just wanted
it released to a committee that was
biased that didn't want the American
people to see everything if you truly
believe that you know January 6 was a
terrible day I think it was a horrible
day we never want to see that happen
again but if you truly believe that
certain things happen show us show
everybody let us see it it will help
your case but if you're not showing it
then you're making us wonder why are you
not showing it so I think it's good for
that to get out if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell